the loud house is one of the hottest
cartoons on Nickelodeon the story of a
large family with ten girls and one boy
made us laugh but what would happen if
the loud family switched genders wait
until you see what Lincoln would look
like as a girl give this video a thumbs
up and don't forget to subscribe if you
want more videos on the loud house now
join us as we explore ten the loud house
characters reimagined as opposite
genders LuAnn loud let's start with
LuAnn loud whose name in the alternate
gender bent universe is lame the loud
house actually did a whole episode on
what the characters would look like as
opposite genders but we are
investigating matters even further the
internet is full of talented artists who
are also part of the loud house fandom
this means we get to see even more
unique versions of what these characters
would look like as opposite genders
check out LuAnn as a fourteen-year-old
girl and one of the oldest in the family
LuAnn is quite the comedian she's full
of bad puns and sometimes terrible jokes
but we adore her for her sense of humor
every family needs a LuAnn in their life
or Lane her male version check out what
lane would look like the first picture
belongs to Cruella De Vil 84 on
deviantart Lane has short brown hair
yellow shorts with straps a white shirt
and the cutest pink bowtie we have ever
seen isn't it just the most adorable
thing ever and here is Lane loud by
Brandon Vance looking terribly angry
he's still rocking that bowtie though
Luann's character was inspired by the
creator sister did you know that Chris
Savino has five sisters and their names
all start with the letter L his family
is just as large as the loud family and
we bet he also sometimes wished he had
more brothers than sisters Lucy loud
Lucy loud as a boy is a very interesting
sight this email looking child is one of
the sassiest eight-year-olds we have
ever seen Lucy is moody and grumpy and
she already acts like she's in her teens
if you have a lot of siblings you've
probably had at least one of them go
through this same phase as Lucy her
alternate boy version is called Lars
loud and he's just as snarky and moody
unlike Lucy Lars is slightly more
aggressive and doesn't get along with
Lincoln Jay boy 32x from deviantART also
created an interesting version of Lucy
as a boy and check this out he also
showed what Lucy and Lars would look
like as a couple
it's a strange thought considering
they're basically the same person but
for some reason this illustration is
really cute if you've ever wondered
where the creativity behind the loud
house characters came from look no
further than the
Gators family Chris savino's family
shares many of the names with the loud
house characters two sisters are even
named after his family's wiener dogs
will tell you more about that later
however Lucy's name is a baby named
Chris would have picked if he had a baby
girl how cute is that speaking of cute
we can't decide who we like better Lucy
or Lars
Lenny loud next on our list is Lenny
loud the 16 year old Lenny is
overprotective loving and somewhat ditzy
but we still love her
as the second oldest in the loud family
she is known to show a lot of love to
her younger siblings in an alternate
universe a boy version of Lenny is named
Lonnie the two share similar
characteristics but Lonnie isn't such a
family person and he doesn't really care
what happens to his younger siblings as
Lenny is a typical girly girl this
transition is pretty interesting check
out the official version of Lonnie it
seems that he replaced Lenny's round
shades for slightly cooler looking
sunglasses and he's totally rocking them
here are a couple more versions of the
character created by a deviantART user
AAAS Russia Lonnie is definitely looking
sassier than Lenny here's another
adorable example of what Lonnie loud
would look like this cute illustration
belongs to at large loud smells good on
Instagram Lonnie definitely still has
Lenny's ditzy and naive characteristics
but what he doesn't have is the love for
his siblings did you know that the loud
house characters were originally
imagined as rabbits Lenny's name didn't
come from Chris savino's family it was a
named Chris gave one of the rabbit
characters and it was originally a boy
named based on the character in Of Mice
and Men Chris then changed the spelling
and turned it into a woman's name Lowell
allowed this six-year-old pageant queen
is one of those siblings that's bound to
get on everyone's nerves like a true
princess Lola is bossy and bratty but
her antics are also totally hilarious
it's hard to imagine what this girly
girl would look like as a typical boy
right
well when the loud house reimagined all
loud sisters as boys they decided to
call Lola Lex Lex is completely
different from this pageant queen
although he's still a prince and he's
totally spoiled lexis also mean to
everyone including Lincoln check him out
sure he has a crown on his head
but unlike Lola Lex isn't sporting a
long pink dress a deviantART user Ian
Kyle 1189 also drew what Lola and Lex
would look like as separate people we
can't decide which one we prefer the
spoiled but funny Lola or the spoiled
but me and Lex we've previously
mentioned that Lola loud has a lot in
common with honey boo boo they're both
pageant queens but
don't you think they also kind of look
alike and yes Lolo is actually named
after Chris savino's wiener dog it looks
like Chris really did manage to turn his
life into an actual cartoon although we
doubt Lola or her male version have any
qualities that are similar to dogs at
least we hope they don't we can't
mention Lola without also talking about
her tomboy twin Lana the two are already
alternate versions of themselves but
Lana also has a male version and his
name is leaf leaf and Lana are quite
similar and shared the same
personalities however leaf is slightly
more aggressive and mean especially
towards Lincoln fans have also created
their own versions of leaf loud
including this one which belongs to
Lewis Olazabal leaf and Lex loud are
posing together and they both look like
they're up to no good
we were always fans of Lana's tomboyish
look and leaf is still rocking that red
snapback we also love this illustration
of leaf loud done by a deviantART user
named the total kid just like Lana leaf
is missing some of his front teeth and
rocking those denim overalls
although Lola was named by a wiener dog
Lana was fortunate enough to be named by
one of Chris savino's sisters did you
know that a lot of the shenanigans
actually come from Chris's real life
experiences he claims that his siblings
have enough sense of humor to never get
upset over what they see on the show
however Lana loud has so many crazy
moments it makes us wonder what the real
Lana was like as a child
Lorie loud as the oldest of the eleven
siblings everyone expects Laurie to be
the overprotective and loving big sister
well while Laurie does have her
overprotective moments she also always
makes sure she lets her siblings know
who's the oldest if you have an older
sibling we're pretty sure you know what
it's like to be constantly told you're
younger than they are
Laurie establishes dominance and treats
her siblings like they're her personal
helpers but her personality still isn't
as mean as her boy version which is
called Loki when Lincoln wished to have
brothers instead of sisters we bet he
never really wished for Loki Loki is
bossy but his looks aren't that much
different from Laurie's check out the
official Loki designed by the loud house
creators we all know Laurie as a total
flirt and Loki is the same deviant arts
Makiki em are also Illustrated a
fantastic version of Loki accidentally
dropping his phone and this talented
deviantART user named Brandon Vance
showed us what Loki and Laurie would
look like if they ever got married
Laurie is also the name of one of Chris
savino sisters but Chris did note that
their namesakes don't match their
personas it's good to know Chris's older
sister was probably nicer than Laurie
Lisa loud Lisa
is probably one of our favorite
characters on the show she was
responsible for bringing together the
world at the loud house with The Fairly
OddParents her clever mind is on a whole
other level which is probably why she
won a Nobel Peace Prize at just four
years old she's pretty incredible right
well wait until you see her alternate
male version Lisa in a boy version is
called Levi Levi is just as talented as
Lisa but he tends to be a bit harsher
and aggressive especially toward Lincoln
Levi has short hair but the rest of him
is pretty similar to Lisa however we
think that Levi also looks like another
popular cartoon character can you see
the resemblance between Levi loud and
dexter from dexters laboratory the two
could basically be the same characters
the loud house fan on deviantART also
created an amazing version of Levi and
replaced his round glasses with slightly
cooler looking shades Makiki mr also
drew his own version of Levi this one is
a bit taller and we can definitely see
that he looks like Dexter could you cope
with having a four year old sister who's
as smart as Lisa we can't decide if we
prefer Lisa or Levi loud but we're sure
that if they both existed in the same
universe they'd come up with some
amazing experiments Lynne loud the 13
year old Lynne is one of the most
athletic and sporty characters on the
show but when you have so many siblings
you usually turn things into a
competition Lynne is super competitive
and likes to win at all times if you
have siblings you probably have at least
one competitive sibling that does this -
Lynne is the only character on the show
that got the same name when she became a
boy the male Lynne lad has a similar
personality same clothing and just
slightly shorter hair he's just as
competitive and maybe just a bit more
abrasive especially towards Lincoln we
wonder why Chris Tavano decided to leave
his name the same speaking of Chris did
you know that his family loves that
they're now part of such a big show he
said he's always getting text messages
whenever someone watches an episode but
the inspiration didn't just come from
Chris's family the show's writers also
frequently discuss things they used to
do as children and then use it in the
show Lynne is also the name of one of
his sisters but unlike her cartoon
version we hope that the real win cut
some slack to other non-competitive
siblings on the other hand no sibling
relationship is complete without a bit
of rivalry right loon allowed the loud
house has so many interesting characters
it's very hard to pick your favorite
Luna is also one of those people that
stand out from the crowd and her
insanely large family this 15 year old
loves rock music and you'll catch her
singing popular rock song throughout the
show and although she's loud and
sometimes wild whoo
one of the most caring out of all the
siblings her looks are unique and she
can rock a purple outfit like nobody
else you can't help but love Lunas
attitude her alternate male version is
called Luke and although he looks the
same his attitude is slightly more
aggressive honestly we're glad Lincoln
has 10 sisters instead of 10 brothers
Michael Eddie drew another version of
Luke and even paired him up with Layne
loud louann's boy version speaking of
Luke loud did you know that he's played
by Greg Cipes who's an actual musician
you might remember his voice from
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles where he
played Michelangelo Luna is always
singing rock song but imagine if Luke
loud would be there to sing the lower
range songs with her the two could
create the ultimate rock band and we'd
be the first ones to buy their album and
we have a feeling they would title their
album after their last name seems
fitting right Lincoln loud if you've
watched the one of the boys episode of
this show you'll know that Lincoln is
the one responsible for turning his
sisters into boys as the only boy of the
family Lincoln has a lot on his plate
and we really feel bad for him because
it's definitely not easy but what would
happen if Lincoln wasn't actually a boy
in the first place check him out this
illustration is done by karela deville
84 and it's absolutely fabulous a female
version of Lincoln has longer hair a
blue skirt and orange blouse and
earrings in the official loud house
episode Lincoln's name as a girl is
linka did you know that Lincoln is
actually the only character with more
than four letters in his name when the
characters were first created they were
rabbit which is why Lincoln is also the
only one that was left with unique white
hair we haven't seen much of the girl
version of linka but Dan McEwan on
deviantART also gave us a good idea of
what Lincoln would look like as a bonus
check out a female version of Lincoln's
best friend Clyde called Claire McBride
after that episode were pretty sure
Lincoln stopped wishing for brothers and
started to enjoy the crazy life with his
10 sisters what about you do you wish
you could have a sister or a brother if
you love the loud house don't forget to
check out videos like 10 the loud house
characters in real life don't forget to
subscribe and hit that thumbs up button
see you next time
[Music]